[Applause]  yeah last time I was here I did my Fresh  Prince rad 8 million YouTube hits was on  that I can see your face you like what  has he left well this time I brought my  DJ Jazzy Jeff  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  oh here we go here we go  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you like that hold up man  for you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  I don't think you're finished yet Jeff I  don't think that better Holly ready  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  okay  [Applause]  a little treat for you dad a little  treat for you a treat  [Applause]  he's Brooklyn he's now Brooklyn Romeo  and Cruz they're all at the Arsenal  Academy yeah and they usually take  pictures with all the fans and then I  felt like this wasn't you know yeah it's  not appropriate right no I